what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are back for the
Mandalorian season 3 episode 7 following
the highest rated episode on IMDb and
all the fans John
oh I'm I'm one with the force and the
forces with me how are you sir I am the
force Michael how are you I am freshly
bathed in the Living Waters of men hey
nice you smell great today thank you oh
what a nice shirt oh yeah we got the
shirts guys
he'll get him soon I ordered mine but
guys thank you again so much in 24 hours
this became the highest selling shirt
over at the real rejects shop
zeroedition.com I just wanted to shout
out Straw Hat Ryan Ryan seghetti on
Twitter because right before filming
this I saw his tweet that he just got
his shirt in the mail as well so thank
you Ryan and thank you to everyone who
got one you can go get your it's a great
way to support the channel we love him
if it's great and it's kind of Evergreen
too as long as Pedro's alive as long as
he's taking care of kids yeah alrighty
guys well thank you so much for being
here you know what to do use the force
to leave a like tell us what you thought
of this episode down in the comments
subscribe click the notification Bell
because you know there's one more
episode left after this let's see where
the direction of this is headed as
always full length Reaction watch along
where you sync up with your own copy
available for a super sexy Rejects at a
Petron page thank you to all who become
super sexy pjx because we cover so many
things over there exclusively with
reaction highlights and watch songs
included well
[Music]
please be your credit
start
dude Blade Runner is so cool yeah that's
where the budget went huh
she straight up is it the decorative
here he is
afraid the Pirates
trouble on Navarro
didn't you suggest that the new Republic
would not be sending support he shaved
bogoton Cruise led a squadron of
mandalorians alongside DIN jarin and his
covert
continue with your mission I shall deal
with our Mandalorian Lori friends this
is where Ben Affleck's Batcave is yeah
what I'm taking this obsidian background
oh [__] what oh no
uh
oh he's been preparing damn Vader's
castle and Mustafar maybe no way
strengths will not be wasted
the grand Admiral thrawn's return will
Herald in the re-emergence of our
military
and provide commandant Huts wow I see
once again
that grand Admiral thrawn is missing
from your delegation wow we're just any
word on when he will be able to
participate in the shadow Council in the
Ahsoka series
our one hope for Success relies upon the
secrecy of his return is that wrong
perhaps it's time we look to new leader
project Necromancer is in place for that
it's a cool name bringing the dead back
to life that sounds like operation
Palpatine three praetorian gods
sounds like someone is concerned about
an assassination attempt and he thinks
I'm being the flashy one Grand Moff
[__] and what is your security concern
mandalorians
what why'd you say that name they are
preparing to retake their home world of
Mandalore which you might be on right
now we shall be rid of the mandalorians
once and for all long live the Empire
good to have you back
yeah yeah seriously they got me back
that was good opener that was very quick
oh yeah we've got a Mando Fleet
not again
[Laughter]
all right Chris Pratt and Charlie day
let's go
where's all my celebrity cameos this is
a Mandalorian without all my celebrity
cameo
vislo is going to be so easy to get
along with oh yeah his his family line
is great history with these people
hug it out
could have waited
for our guests
coming into the whole planet to do a
feast I'll go out in their separate
areas that's quite a fleet you've
assembled
welcome gift Chateau Picard that's all
the way from Coruscant so you might want
to wait for a smaller gathering before
you open it throw it against the ship
that's not the only gift I have for you
foreign
take a spin-off movie awaits
what a little Baboo
oh that's ig-12 now do you like him do I
like him
oh it's more like a vehicle
hmm it's safer that way
[Music]
baby
[Laughter]
this is
gonna be a great action figure that's
what's missing Gundam grogu yeah there
you go I was like something's wrong with
me today I can ride around inside of
your chest cavity the girl who is too
young to operate heavy machinery maybe
when he's older no
what do you mean no
I think he's saying he's old enough to
operate it yes oh man I'm 52 years old
no at least let him try it out in my
office yes no this is not a good idea
come on
oh choke him oh boy
can't possibly round dad
oh grogu's teenage phase is upon us yes
yes what
yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
that's a boss yes oh my God this is so
annoying yes
stop it
this is their master plan to turn us all
against us
[__]
no yes
[Laughter]
it has too much power
this isn't working for me
I'm loving this right now at so many
levels
I want to eat leave Navarro and move the
fleet into orbit above Mandalore find
out what remains of the great Forge and
establish a safe perimeter she
enunciates so well I need volunteers
from both tribes
God this is just like Remember the
Titans
come on Coach that's exactly what it is
I will go
as well
yes yes yes
[Laughter]
all right
past it's your turn I will go
I will go
we'll go thank you high school yeah I
will go as well oh oh wow that's a risky
even she's surprised be a good time to
accidentally have Bo die and murder her
I mean someone's gonna die right
no
no I think it's all gonna work out just
fine
you know who's gonna die is grief cargo
and everyone on Navarro who just lost
their protection details
just got here
foreign
gorgeous my God
hell yeah
I love this storm in the beach is a
Normandy gonna get those Imperial Nazis
a nice pan
to have holy [__] wow it's like Edge of
Tomorrow sure yeah
I was here when it happened
oh
can hear the directions just a little
little disbelief little head nods
[Music]
let's go
oh man great Power Rangers
best directed episodes are the ones when
they take place on Mandalore
this is a family
we start scouting in that direction
so happy
okay
either the main guy on her side is
what's this guy's name the other guy
yeah it doesn't matter all right 12
seconds he's gonna die or pass is gonna
die it's one of those two they're giving
too much screen times today
that's true
I could just watch them do the walk all
day yeah honestly that's really all I
wanted this whole series
thank you
whoa the [__]
flanking left
yes yes yes bring it on
sailboat fight
oh that's cool it's a dirigible I wonder
if there's more mandalorians out there
you wear the crest of the night owls
they're mandalorians
Mr pfeiffers
is that the voice of lady volca oh my
God
it is
oh boy oh
her shoulder pads kind of looked like an
imperial Commandos we have failed you
but our blasters remain in your service
oh my
God
that's less conflicting than we all
thought and they got a sailboat they
punished us because we refused to
surrender that's
did surrender
awkward I met with Mafia in exchange for
submitting to the Empire and disarming
all remaining cities and Mandalorian
lives were to be spared
oh that is how mothkadian came to
possess the darksaber
12. I never been honest and then he
betrayed me and
we were helpless to
is a dick Mandalore has always been too
powerful for any enemy to defeat
that's right it is always our own
division
that destroys us
start throwing your food at each other
[Laughter]
man I get like at Worlds and Vibe the
third Pirates movie I really really
think the armor might be a follower of
maul from back in the day we were taught
that everyone but us had forsaken the
way
that you were selfish and uncaring a
total [__]
I don't know if I can keep everyone
together and this blade is all I have to
unify our people
I only know of this weapon what you
taught me to be honest it means nothing
to me or my people
what means more to me is honor
and loyalty and character these are the
reasons I serve you lady Crees
wow your song is not yet written
I will serve you until it is as a
supporting character in the series a
song of crease and saber they should
marry and that would that would
definitely help I could finally take my
helmet off I'm the first husband of
Mandalore
I'm kind of here for it though
it's interesting we got this like
Wanderers at Sea Vibe onward
mandalorians
Forge
yeah now we're definitely good in Game
of Thrones fives now this is like an
epic apocalyptic landscape episode mad
mandalorians a little bit of Water World
sprinkled on top of them just the first
side I was thinking that a thousand
percent
all right
see I'm cool with just a season of this
I think everybody is
I've got a bad feeling about this
okay maybe no one dies this episode the
next one
it's a flight job and you're about to
submit but only the wing guard can flank
John
well even their chess is played
culturally different these Primitives
make up their own rules for everything
there was no need for that
oh boy
seriously fear is the mind killer
great shot
oh boy this is not necessary guys it was
going a little too well though it was
bound to happen sooner or later
oh
come on earn some respect
who's your money on
uh
uh crawly boy has lots of more yeah
floatstar
oh man that's not over oh
no
foundling is right
oh wow that was really touching you
touch your print as well
you didn't learn that from me
I learned that from two years with Luke
Skywalker off screen
oh God it's so sad
nah this is the plan all along this is
the way
something just does not feel great right
now
come in please
smart to have that opening you just feel
that danger looming yeah you don't know
which direction it's gonna come from I
do love how well organized the Imperial
Remnant is
oh
interesting I can't believe my eyes the
obsidian that we saw on the walls of
Gideon's Fortress Yeah it's definitely
Mandalore
oh wow
it's either that or Gideon Gideon riding
the myths
here we go damn
oh
wow
yep no [__]
way to go girl good
we'll miss the Black Pearl
release the Kraken
we're after a terrible start run away
was that the mythosaur though I think
that was a different creature missing
the signature horns
jet packs
why this
nope
oh there they are there they are the
real super Commandos
come on Doria
that's super cool seeing them in live
action we're pinned down we need backup
okay
no too far I couldn't make it no I'll
lay down cover Gomez
look at y'all working together
ah man
this is freaking awesome dude this one
really is cool with that gun
[Music]
oh God damn
they are formidable mandalorians
[Music]
oh what's left of Clan Saxon
cool that's a great shot
[Music]
nice man okay kid you've got to keep up
the music oh boy
[Music]
oh I just got chills everywhere
ah sweets
where is he awesome
you gotta be getting close
it's a trap
[Music]
oh darf discovery
it really is a trap it's a tomb
yep
oh
oh my God no come on Den
no
oh what a bunch of [__]
oh wow
oh he upgraded
disarm him
[Music]
yeah it's gonna take a while culturally
appropriates up a storm
it looks extraordinary doing it
I put this on for five minutes you were
a talented people
but your time has passed Mandalore will
live on in
I have created the Next Generation Dark
Trooper suit forged from bescar
what an [__] why don't we take your
Fleet off the board
while we still have the element of
surprise activate the interceptors and
bombers no no no damn it well they tried
oh no [__] the armor is up there isn't
it yeah yeah but we got one fellow that
escaped so maybe they have enough
warning to uh
maybe The Purge of Mandalore will be
complete take him to the debriefing room
give him a thorough explanation of
everything I just said Bo Catan
we have to stop meeting like this
I believe this is the part where you
return the dark saber to its rightful
Come and Get It surrender the darksaber
and tell these people that this planet
is mine
how's it go let it go
yeah come on kill them
uh pass is not gonna fit in that hole
[Music]
come on
rats yeah
I gotta get more of those mini guns
all right hopefully his son will turn
down as roided up as he did
uh don't be a hero pass
go there are too many
oh what a way to go out Fabs oh I've
just had like Goosebumps this last few
minutes
God look at the barrels just burning up
oh boy
it's overheating
Whack Him With It
throw it yeah boy
love a good gun throw
single-handedly defeated all the
Imperials to go Wilson's Fishbone
survive for a little longer
oh no
the preteratorian guards yeah damn it
oh
[__] damn
let's get it done
right now I really wish you would have
won the dark saver oh man
[Music]
oh yeah
there's a wild episode
oh my God they got brutal ass death
no okay yeah there's no chance he's
alive uh get him in a back to tank
wow
it was a family episode
see when you get both of them to write
together you get something great hard
and the cannon this is a perfect
follow-up after the hilarious episode
that came prior definitely feels like a
direct tonal continuation
it is the same show right I'm not
missing something I think Rick famuiwa
is my favorite Mandalorian director oh
for sure he's been really consistent the
first 10 to 15 minutes I found myself a
little bit on guard
sure I was like of course don't don't
let it down just yet man let's just wait
how the rest of this goes every once in
a while the show knows how to wrap it up
in two episodes
has crammed the entire story you were
hoping for I just did the two just
remember in the last season of Game of
Thrones being like okay
where are the dangers down here but no
they
are pulling it back all right guys
Disney Star Wars back on top
ratings are through the roof the company
is safe company's safe everything's fine
I'm excited about those announcements
glad that's over Bob Iger wrote this
episode
uh yeah I thought this was a great
episode I thought that they did it all
the things that you would want from a
solid Mandalorian episode
um you know I wish Studios would just
cooperate and not drop things so early
in the morning on Tuesdays and then
because then we gotta shoot this at
midnight but if it's like 5 30 in the
morning I feel like I'm gonna be
especially loopy during this discussion
right now we got just been prepared I
got a conserve energy for the edit
tonight
um but no I thought this was a fantastic
just felt like this wave like oh zoning
out ready to go let's Lock and Load
let's go yeah I thought that this
episode was directed wonderfully I mean
the the second episode in this one are
usually my favorites of the season so
far and it's funny they both take place
on Mandalore I feel like this is where
they care the most and everything from
the sound design and the atmosphere
building and just the overall mood you
know like you you get a sense at the
forlorn history with the other
characters that you're picking up with
as well I thought it was
it had a a real like mood about it that
uh I I could and that's all you could
really ask for sometimes like if you
don't have time to like get into the
specifics and the exposition of these
characters sometimes all you need is
just capturing the right Essence to know
okay I understand the experience prior
to this while you're giving me the
exposition of what going on like to me
some people are fine when it comes to I
got context and I like context and to me
I'm like well I I personally need
context and good filmmaking a good
storytelling and well-written dialogue
and you know I need I need all that I
don't know I don't understand why
because sometimes people can just like
look past all that and just go I love
what the context is good you know and I
thought to me this in really encompassed
all that like moth Gideon I remembered
feeling uh towards the end of season two
you just started feeling a little campy
let's start feeling a little goofy uh
like I've always liked Giancarlo
Esposito yeah but here it brought it
brought back that Menace you know that
he you felt when he first showed up in
this series yeah you know when he first
showed up on Navarro and here I thought
they really brought it back but yeah
when we saw the chicken restaurant while
they were flying in I was like oh man
this is gonna get real good tie into
everything I've been waiting for it to
tie into those Manos Mandos but I feel
like we all love this episode right for
the most part yeah I mean it was it was
a wonderful return to exactly why we
love the Mandalorian but also like it
took that really big leap forward that
I've been waiting for for a long time
now where
it needed to capture that essence of
something bigger and it was a really
hard transition for them this season and
this was the first episode where I
thought they really really stuck The
Landing in making that transition uh it
it in Mandalore you have this setting
that is both ancient and apocalyptic and
and it's textured and it feels different
from everything else we've seen but it
it to your point it's so lived in
um and and it's really the first time
that uh I'm just like really
I believe what's happening yeah which is
just a wonderful feeling yeah because
I've had my complaints about the way
some of the visuals are done in the
season and this episode was like same
thing with the second episode where they
put the budget I don't feel that I feel
this reminds me of like the first second
season a little bit more of that gritty
tone uh but let's dive into some
specifics John I'm gonna set you up for
Success here are you feeling nothing
wrong
see his blue ass show up
no I mean I'm curious though just really
quick like I'll be through all this [__]
when I was so good dress like there's
other there's other thrawn wait man like
there's been Rebels and all that uh but
did you how do you feel as someone who
is not informed on thrawn how do you how
do you feel as a viewer here sitting
going
they're building up this guy yeah yeah
they're building up another big bad I I
mean it's only as good to me as the
episode is because yeah not having I
mean I've seen Admiral thrawn Grand
Admiral thrawn I don't have much direct
experience so yeah I mean to me it's
sort of like okay we're just building up
another big bad who I understand already
has a reputation so like I'm here for it
I'm with it
um and now it just all most of my
association with what they're doing with
that is based on what I've heard from
people up until now and they haven't
really done anything to make me go I
don't think this thrawn stuff's gonna
pan out yeah you know and I like seeing
them you know bicker about like well
where is he now you know like if he's
such a a big player in this operation
and if we're all going to re-establish
the the holds of the Empire why isn't he
showing up why all the secrecy and uh
and yeah I think that's a nice way to
draw that tension out for a viewer like
me who's like I keep hearing about this
guy
um but yeah I mean he certainly seems
like a convincingly foreboding presence
up till now and I think it's good that
they a re-established
um off Gideon as a formidable presence
as well and a presence who is like steps
ahead of the game and is like you know
really cunning and crafty and a
self-anointed rival which is something
that like as we delve into the Imperial
Remnant I think that's just one of the
really fun parts of it is you know all
all season we've been hearing about
these Imperial Warlords and then to
discover you know with the shadow
Council that there is that kind of
concerted effort but between that you've
got a lot of egomaniacs all vying for
control uh and nobody that quite fits
into the emperor's slippers well I've
been reading the I've been reading the
heir to the Empire uh comic adaptation
and I've been reading this Ron comic
adaptation as well
don't tell me to read the goddamn novel
oh I want the pictures uh so I have a
YouTube version I want the kids no no I
need to read it I don't know I need to
feel like I need to feel like I
accomplished something yes
and I've been reading that and it is
interesting like when you're when
especially reading the thrawn arc and
then you're getting moth Gideon here
where you see how thrawn is is always is
this master strategist who can rise
through the ranks and piss off all the
wrong people yeah and you got someone
like moff who resembles that so much of
you know you guys keep wanting him but
I'm better I'm you know Mercy you know
Mercy I'm here you guys keep wanting
that throne but where is he you know I'm
the one taking showers with the Living
Waters
but knowing the the I mean obviously you
know so much we've actually read the
novels and [__] but knowing so much more
about thrawn but with the limited
information that I have on him uh I love
knowing that oh but he's just he's just
building it up in the shadows right now
I mean I think what I'm most excited
about for those who haven't read the
books or or Comics or or even seen
Rebels is that thrawn is of of all Star
Wars villains the most complex and
interesting and I would argue might not
even be a villain uh which he doesn't
come across that one no well as you kind
of get the bigger picture uh which is
beginning to come into Focus uh I did
think what was really interesting is uh
the fella that was in the shadow Council
talking about thrawn uh so he was part
of the seventh fleet and he was actually
that was thrawn's really big Armada and
when thrawn fundamentally disappeared
from the known Galaxy uh that was the
last time unless they have some way to
communicate which I don't know or think
they do based on on where thrawn ended
up uh and so that speaks a lot about
thrawn it's been a long time since he he
went M.I.A so uh it was also it was
great seeing hux uh that was uh General
hux's dad uh which is oh holy [__]
really
yeah well and that's okay Greg uh and it
was played by his brother
really really smart casting uh that's
fun yeah I know it was it's really nice
to see that I'm really curious how they
tie it in because canonically hux
follows a different Wing that ends up
becoming the New Order and I'm I'm
really I hope that we get to explore the
Imperial in fighting a little bit sure
in the next I'm all about that hux
that's where I've been championing for a
lot more hooks all right so we got some
things to really touch on though uh
Vizsla dying was
kind of expected I guess I was down to
two people for me it's like one of the
two it's just right it's the show seemed
like it was gonna be one of those two
he's coming back uh and then he did have
an epic death yeah and I thought I cared
more about his death than I expected
because Vizsla while I I think always
had a great brooding presence about
himself I've I've never been like the
most emotionally invested in the guy I
feel like the show tried giving us an
effort by being like he's got a kid he's
a dad yeah yeah it's like oh there is a
guy underneath the tough exterior
underneath the helmet knife yeah and
then the way he like comes around is
someone who's closed off but then we'll
show his support in a way where you
might not most expect it they've they've
had that with this character and he's
had some real badass scenes and I
thought he had a great way to to go out
you know you gotta say this is the way
twice true and I think the use of the
praetorian guards to take him down was
really really honorable uh yeah like
especially when we had that moment uh
after the Imperial super Commandos death
Trippers uh got their asses he said the
the Troopers was it just really quick it
was moff Gideon saying that uh
his suit is in baskar or the trooper
suits her in basketball Troopers the
Troopers the Troopers which which
started when they recruited gar Saxon
and and the Imperial super Commandos who
were
bad mandalorians uh and so bad those how
do I sum this up in a Korean
mandalorians the not nice ones
um yeah no I thought that was
established in the show in Rebels yeah
it was yeah yeah the uh gar Saxon from
Clan Saxon from house fees look come on
yeah anyway uh but him and his brother
end up getting oh my goodness it's fine
uh but this is what's left of them
um and it was really really cool to see
that live-action adaptation uh and to
see that they've moved fully on to
beskar uh something that I'm I'm curious
if it will get brought up or if they're
just gonna leave it in the in the in the
past is uh Sabine wren's Duchess that
she built that was the the Imperial
weapon designed to attack beskar
um I remember that yeah it was
terrifying
the Thanos snap is this but yeah I mean
it I'm I'm curious to see what other
elements they'll they'll pull from there
um but also the bow Revelation uh about
surrendering to moff Gideon
yeah thought of a physical bow yeah all
that archery
well for the bad batch fans yeah
that was surprising because I think a
lot of us thought that he challenged her
and she lost
no no way no she would have to die then
right no I mean you can you can you can
just yield
yes
they talked about that we've been here
this is what I was worried about
everyone
it's okay yeah this is the way I do
appreciate though with with Bo's Arc
that she's made it abundantly clear that
she does not feel the dark saber is a
big enough symbol to get all the
mandalorians to stay together
for a moment I thought it was the
mythosaur but now I'm realizing it's
grogu's heart it's gonna be the thing to
save the day well they had this there's
been a complaint about the show
um that what I understand there's a few
well one complaints
I mean have fetty episodes even made it
more clear it's this one how he has
become
not even really sometimes it didn't feel
like he's a supporting characters
he's just a Mandalorian now yeah he
doesn't feel like the men but I no here
he is the full on supporting character
um in a more defined way like he is
literally in support for Boca tons you
have my ax and my bow
The Fellowship of the boat and I prefer
if you're gonna take that Direction with
him that I prefer to take a Direction
with making a supporting character than
you make of the ultimate supporting
character and I did like the speech that
he does give to Boca 10 and I do I would
simp them simple Orion with them I would
I would absolutely there's
[__]
I would absolutely love for them to get
it but it doesn't need to go that way
either uh but you do see a bit of a
family Trio there if you see this guy's
always riding on her lap well I like the
tension that they draw out of that and I
think us sitting here going like okay
the armorer poker tan what's their whole
thing together are they on the same page
and like I like that they ring so much
out of that and things like oh you know
katannon didn't try and beat together or
anything like that like they're really
good at ringing the real tension out of
all those different juxtapositions well
they played the audience too in in the
same way that I mean this whole season
has been about
mandalorian's greatest adversary has
always been the mandalorians and they
made us as an audience feel that same
way and get super defensive and
concerned to be like well the armorer is
going to kill Beau like yeah I don't
know the armor what she's been saying is
true yeah
oh I guess she's just doing her thing I
guess I'm usually not one to be like huh
that religious zealot's really on to
something yeah but in this particular
case
they might be so uh this episode had the
most I think of any of them this season
that felt like I was peering on to a it
felt the most like a Lord of the Rings
style map where you're like oh wow we're
finally filling in a part and I could
feel all the other parts kind of alive
across trap but we're not really
focusing on those right now and I
thought the way they represented the
Imperials the mandalorians all that
stuff made the map like I I like a silly
last week I enjoy that for different
reasons but this was the most this
season it's felt like a truly
interconnected big sprawling world that
we're just shining a light on one
significant part of that will
interconnect with a bunch of other
significant Parts yeah I do kind of wish
that they cut out some other stuff in
other episodes because when you have
episodes like this it shows you like
what they're capable of yeah what the
strengths of this show can be and
there's been a lot of build up too
especially with these two camps meeting
together and didn't really do much with
it yeah I mean it was well it so many
things have had to be rushed because of
how much time we've spent in in other
places and they do it they do gloss over
like they missed a couple things yeah
they made good beats out of those
tensions in this episode and a couple
other points but it should have been it
should have been remembered
yeah like the season should have like a
strong significance
but instead we got Roku 2 in this which
was really sweet
so I I yeah I'm completely there with it
how do you feel about uh as the note
here says
um how do you feel about a robo it's
about time he got another upgrade he's
gonna be like really The Matrix
Revolution too yeah
is going to be like a Katamari like by
the end of the series he's gonna have
his chainmail he's gonna have like all
sorts of different accoutrements from
all across the gal he's gonna be like
the Nexus point of all cultures it's
it's definitely the coolest action
figure set that's ever been made by Star
Wars I mean listen if if the note was
you have to keep grogu
I can't lie like I'm really happy with
the direction that Kroger's going I wish
he was still studying with Luke but you
know I get it yeah shareholders all
these should just take place on weekends
and then Mando Picks Them Up Oh joint
joint custody sounds like a great idea
yeah you can't help but sometimes let
your mind Trail off onto oh what this
season could have been if it was like
you cut back to grogu once in a while
training and you're seeing like Den
dealing with the grief of having to let
grogu go yeah and then maybe grogu
having like a Luke moment uh in Return
of the Jedi be in the Empire rather uh
needing to be like I need to go rescue
my friends The Last Jedi where Luke
almost kills him way too powerful kids
trying to kill me
what do you think grogu ran away and he
started the Knights of rent yeah we're
gonna explain everything guys everything
yeah I think that's a neat tie-in I'm
happy with
I think that's really cool the den art
is uh satisfactory enough for me why not
all with the punches my my gut says this
I think if they're serious about keeping
din in a major way he's gonna be the one
to end up with the mythosaur
I think he deserves it at least because
that is a true
like the dark saber means nothing to the
guy it doesn't and so to me I wasn't
even like a lot of people were really
upset about him like not I didn't I
didn't go home and be sad I didn't do
that I didn't even give a [__] I was
like more like I don't like the way it
was executed but made him do it in the
cave the first time she said yeah
because like it means nothing to him but
the mythosar means something to him and
his culture and and he's gonna name him
razor Crest
no but it does like I mean they they
even brought up the myths are uh way
back in in the second episode of yeah I
mean it's always been around before but
it's been indoctrine and it's at the
culture and the the iconography all the
imagery right
um but I remember it was quill who was
the first one to mention like writing
the mythosar in the second episode so
yeah this is something that I think has
been foreshadow if they don't do it they
make freaking that then I'm upset I
don't really care about him listen
I'm happy for Bo I love Beau as a
character but like let's give din
something uh but the two of them coming
together I mean that's Boba Fett
what I want to see is the Tuscan Writers
come and help uh yeah yeah with Boba
Fett yeah and uh uh and what's her name
uh and John no no no no the the oh my
goodness our wonderful who built him the
Starfighter uh pillow oh
thank you of course my girl yeah that's
what I'm saying I think she's the one
that saves them in the end telemoto
let's hope so yeah
will come in we'll come in all right
guys well what do you think what did you
think what are your theories for how the
finale is going to go down uh I thought
this was the I still
personally prefer the second episode
yeah no me too it's like my second
favorite that was the Cave episode back
and forth you just had so much more
possibility ahead of you during that
secular thing we're like wow if this
whole season's gonna be this this is
gonna be sick
come back
no I have to say I still don't think
that that alleged Imperial spy is bad
sure what I think she's a good character
and that love is love I hope so all
right guys what did you think about this
episode leave your thoughts down below
you can go grab yourself a last daddy
shirt do it it's really nice hey let's
end this with a patron
Michael Linden Mikhail you're from
Sweden you know what I found out about
Swedish people recently oh
they get like so much paid time off oh
yeah they work people like people you
get
weeks what kind of confidence nonsense
is that child they make sure you get
like at least a month off and you get
really good pay for it and they and they
kind of enforce that you relax they're
like don't work does that mean that the
real rejects is subsidized by the
Swedish government kale
I want you to use your vacation money to
up your pledge right now because that's
the American attitude sure investment
capitalism invest in us and then not see
a profit return nope yeah
we don't treat people like people yeah
no need for that [__] around here
Mikhail come on what are you doing with
that vacation money sleep
recycle the money back into US
inflation's High we need your
vacationing we're working yeah so come
on man send those good good Euros up the
attitude a little bit here in a more
positive direction
attitude increases altitude over the
phrases what does it say you miss a
hundred percent of the shots you don't
take Michael Scott Wayne Gretzky
but Mikhail thank you so much for being
part of our page my friend I hope you
are enjoying
your non-word and I hear that even when
you're actually working you're just like
smoking hookah and uh even prison's nice
there people want to go to prison
everyone goes to prison no one works and
somehow the country just runs on its own
thanks Mikhail